how's the gum resin welcome to Christmas
shopping simulator hey you want a gift
I'll give you the gift of love [ __ ] Oh
double kale haha
I can't wait to do some shopping with
your breads oh it's a ripoff of goat
simulator let's play it I can either be
demon from Hell or board demon from hell
I'll go with board demon thank you oh
good but I mistook my hair alright
that's my super ability I guess that's
great
who needs a haircut anyway I better
answer the phone
that's how we answer it uncle Steve
loves shampoo buy some and then God
there goes my hair again I'm eight hey
Shampoo shampoo up that's not the
shampoo hey what the hell am I doing
with this Abbi oh here's a shampoo hey
man I wanted some of this please sorry
temple please get me that shampoo and no
one will get hurt
thanks oh she wrapped it for me alright
where do I go I place it in here what
the [ __ ] is she let's ride Rudolph let's
ride Rudolph number two all right well
let's get let's grab one of these or not
semi hand what happened to my ad the
[ __ ] is this ah what the [ __ ] is this
I'm bull Vereen apparently yes mate now
excuse me girl what are you doing sorry
whoa Jesus Christ kill it hey man you
need help ah gotta love how I walk
so good let's jump down ah I'm fine how
are these ladies doing taking me girl
take me can't stop being sexy kidding oh
sorry oh I brought a peasant this is
great I visit the game store what the
[ __ ] is happening
ah who said video games causes violence
I don't understand hey how you doin girl
don't mind me I'm just an ice skating
man I need to get my my wha wha wha this
one place and the new FIFA
Thanks what is happening to me Oh No
please please do something so Oh God oh
my god what is happening Jesus Christ
this camp is out of control
oh my god space monkey whoa a my space I
imagine this is what space feels like
the [ __ ] is wrong with my guy oh my god
stop what is he doing what's that guy
doing hey Jerry stop looking at me oh
god that's terrifying
Oh God aah what is that I've seen my
insides that's more than I ever wanted
to see I gotta give this game points for
realism at least oh Jesus Christ
ha ha ha no dancing rudolf stop trying
to [ __ ] my face
Jesus hey OH catch Thanks
I'm tired now this is how I walk these
days I'm a turtle gotta make it to the
game store ah so a little energy though
ah yeah yeah yeah you know [ __ ] it we're
buying the largest TV I can find all
right ha got it gives me sorry I would
like this television please there we go
nailed Angie I said ah never mind my
[ __ ] head where did he go either this
oh god no television come back here I
swear to God you come back here
television dammit dammit
oh I just want my television and I only
happens during this time of year there
we go got it
excuse me excuse me hey you want a gift
I'll give you the gift of love [ __ ]
Oh double kale ha ha ha I need to sneak
in here
okay excuse me and being stealthy and
sneaky here gives me notice just need to
get there somehow can't stop twerking
for some reason this is my excitement
when I get a new game hey it's my game
[ __ ] hey hey stop stop nope my mind a
mind game stop a bag I'm running [ __ ]
running ere we go oh I want this oh oh
my god I didn't even break the glass
I mean oops just spreading the love of
Christmas that's all I ever care about I
came in like a peasant ball what what
the [ __ ] alright flu let's do a Bunga
jump you stay here
wait how way everybody like hey my
haircut disappeared again alright for us
I've down there have a great Christmas
don't buy gifts like this and don't lose
your hair while you buy your gifts leave
like you're watching brothers hit
subscribe come read today I will see you
in the next one as always thank you for
watching stay awesome